ok now let's check this out let's see if
I can go through this process and we can
confirm or reject or seal we're going to
do with this okay I'm since I've already
drawn up on the board let's give out all
stations to central a bit of a workout
here okay so what I'm first going to do
is I'm going to say well so this is what
we're going to do testing well if sine x
equals root 3 on 2 you can do one of two
things at this point ok you can
hopefully start to recognize route 302
that's going to be one of your exact
values he can take aha I know what the
first solution will be for sure it's
going to be 60 degrees okay
alternatively you can reach for your
calculator your sine inverse of energy
and it will also need you back 60
degrees okay so there's our first
solution then you need to ask the
question well what would the other one
being or others right sometimes they can
be more than another one so I'm going to
take this angle and I'm going to
recognize that side is positive see that
I mean there's a plus sign it's just
hiding there because we don't need to
write it okay so can one being that site
is positive which of these four
quadrants army am I in I'm already at
the first 160 degrees is a first
quadrant angle which other quadrant is
so positive it's the second quadrant
right all stations to central really
stands for all functions sine tear and
cards so I'm in the second one right in
the second wasn't in the second quadrant
what I do with this angle is I go 180
degrees take away Matt now six so I 240
is going to give me a third quadrant
angle okay so it is an answer it's just
unfortunately not going to give me the
answer that I want in fact and you can
really calculate it out to double check
this if you were to put inside 240 I can
guarantee you what your game is not
referring to but negative root 3 on 2
okay it's going to be the same size but
it will be negative instead of positive
okay so very close good effort but how I
know that it's going to be take away
rather than plus is I want an angle in
this range I want an angle in the second
quadrant so that sign we positive so
therefore
this is actually going to 120 degrees
like what is 60 okay and look about if
you got to 40 as well this is the whole
reason why we're going through these so
that we can confirm we know what to do
hi now just really quickly before I
leave off this how would I do this
graphically without drawing
such-and-such recorder I would look at
this I'd say okay let's try out a really
really rough sine X / there's a rough so
next curve okay x equals 60 degrees i'm
going to get that angle the same way
that i got the angle in the first place
so with my calculator or remembering my
exact values and then i'll say okay
route 302 is going to be somewhere
around yeah ok so the chit answers I'm
expecting a here and here right so I'm
going to say there's the 60 degrees that
my calculator all my memory first told
me and then this second angle will be
180 take away at 60 which is what gives
me 120 as well okay so there's my rough
sketch that's all I would need to get
supposed two angles 6120 all right great
let's have another go over to who's gone
there to turn number to someone else if
cos x yeah all right um to 10 and 3 30
okay we're going to try out x equals 2
10 or 330 let's test this out okay so I
see causes negative right good morning
cause negative so when I have a look in
these quadrants right this one's outfits
positive this one's outfits positive I
want the second and a third quadrant
angle that's the pair of angles I'm
looking for okay so how am I going to
find out the size of an angle first I
need to find out what that basic that
small acute angle is so I'm going to go
every lose cos inverse of root fiocchi
you see that's how I ignore the sign to
find out just that basic small angle
okay and that should be 30 degrees do we
agree okay that's what it's getting and
again that's another exact value right
so what do I do with this 30 I say in
the second
sorry yeah the second quadrant right
where closets leave you I'm going to go
180 take away at that angle all right so
I'm going to go 180 take away 30 and
then in the third quadrant I'm going to
go 180 plus x 180 plus okay so it's
going to give me again I've got one
answer in common right but I've miss lon
which is fine this guy over here this
guy is 150 and this one is the one we
got before 210 okay now what would
happen if i put in 3 30 because that
year's like one of these related angles
right well you can see what I'll get
because I'm in the fourth quadrant will
not be minus return to but positive
returns you and you can again check it
out Chuck Close 313 year calculator is
one of great things about this kind of
tree that you never need to be in doubt
like it's all right if you make a
mistake yard boom I'll just check I have
this wonderful tool they can just tell
me confirm for me whether I got it right
or not okay and you will see oh it's
close but not quite so therefore i'll
put in my second quadrant angle there
again just to quickly rehearse how would
i do that with a graph okay let me draw
help if i open my wife a marker let me
draw a really rough version of cos x
okay because that's the kind of function
i'm looking at is cause ok now where are
the answers I'm expecting I want it to
be negative root 3 on 2 so negative 3 3
on 2 is going to be down here okay so
where are these two answers i'm getting
here they are here and here alright so
the calculor is going to tell me right
to go to this angle here is 30 degrees
from the middle you see how i'm using
the symmetry to my advantage so i go 30
degrees that way which gives me 150 and
then i go 30 degrees this way which
gives me to 10 man with their ok right
let's go through these last few a bit
quicker this time i will i'll skip the
graph because again it does take a bit
longer if you're less familiar
and on this will give you the right
results so long as you know what's going
on right so I've got 10 x equals
negative 1 right what would be my basic
angle my small angle it's going to be 45
right and I get that by saying 10
inverse of 1 just by itself without the
Sun you're a bear and that hands you on
that hands you 25 so what do I do with
my 45 degrees I say Ted supposed to be
negative which quadrants am i interested
in quadrant two and four quadra for
right you can see here they're all
positive that's out here 10 is positive
that's at as well so i'm left with two
or four ok so in Quadrant 2 X is going
to be 100 take away at 45 degrees and
quadrant 4 i'm going to be 360 take away
the 45 degrees that you told me all
right so that's going to give the 135 or
what's this one through fantastic 315
BAM and again you can check your
calculator 10 135 it gives us negative 1
as expected and 10 3 15 same result okay
so by the way you can also remember 10
is periodic every 180 degrees he copies
himself every 180 degrees so if you
wanted to would it be that hard to guess
what the next solution would be the next
solution after this guy from here to
here you add 180 from here the next one
add 18 can get four hundred and
ninety-five degrees or deny fine let's
just quickly test it because we have a
calculator why not you ten of 495 lo and
behold you get your negative one ok